in gke application owners can define the
minimum
and maximum amount of cpu and memory
that their workloads require
this is done in the form of per
container requests and limits in a
kubernetes pod
this process isn't perfect though
workload requirements may need to change
over time for many reasons
from incoming demand on the applications
to improper initial configuration
app rightsizing is the practice of
fine-tuning workload requests over time
to ensure that their requests accurately
reflect what the workloads will utilize
in order to make gke cost optimization a
discipline
it's important to provide a monitoring
system that can help teams practice app
right sizing
[Music]
previously we discussed how it is
important to monitor cluster bin packing
or how efficiently resources are
distributed at a cluster and no pool
level
signals of poor utilization at these
aggregated levels
can be indicative of applications being
over or under-provisioned
monitoring at the application level can
empower application owners to have the
right data
to right-size their apps and put gke
cost optimization
into practice
to monitor this effectively we want to
ensure that clusters utilize namespaces
in a logical fashion
for many reasons we do not want to have
a single namespace running all pods
these include overly permissive
role-based access control
inability to set quotas per team the
list goes on
but from a monitoring perspective we
want to be able to utilize namespaces to
understand app
rightsizing patterns across groups of
applications
a common example of how this could be
useful would be for namespaces to be
aligned to each
team this easily allows us to then chart
and monitor how each team is doing
for example when a team is consistently
over provisioned
on a specific resource across multiple
apps
we can make that information available
to them this builds a culture
around empowering teams to right-size
their apps
the way we can detect how well they're
doing is by utilizing platform-specific
recommendations
for example the vertical pod auto-scaler
this means that we'll get recommended
values for cpu and memory requests
which we can chart against the actual
resources that pods are requesting in
that given namespace
once we have a team to work with on
right-sizing apps
we can then dig into monitoring for
their over-provisioned apps
the data we've already collected for the
aggregate namespace view will be
utilized here as well
this time on a per workload basis
here we can see that the front end and
backend workloads for team a
are well over provisioned
so what can we do now we can start with
auto-generated recommendations from
vertical pod autoscaler
this may give us quick easy guidance to
right-size over-provisioned apps by
reducing cpu and memory requests
we should also create per application
dashboards where we graph out data
including what resources
the pods are utilizing what the sum of
requests and limits for those pods are
and how their utilization compares to
their target utilization defined by a
horizontal pod auto scaler
note that in this example we have the
horizontal pod auto scaler's target
utilization
for a set of pods well above actual
utilization
this introduces an opportunity for cost
optimization by app right sizing
when we have average utilization well
below the target utilization defined
in the horizontal pod auto scaler we can
consider lowering the number of minimum
replicas
by reducing this count we get to reduce
the cost of running this application
all while maintaining flexibility to
still scale up to handle varying load
while we have mainly focused on cost
optimization with the goal of reducing
cluster costs
it's a good time to remind ourselves
that cost optimization and practicing
phenoms
is the discipline of balancing costs
with other critical areas
with this same data we can also monitor
for under-provisioned apps as well
which are opportunities for right-sizing
apps for the sake of performance and
stability
over time you'll find that cluster bin
packing and app right sizing are
intertwined exercises
due to events such as the onboarding of
entirely new apps into a cluster
configuring a monitoring system around
the topics discussed here can be complex
so be sure to check out the guide we
published on how to set one up
with a system set up for cluster bin
packing and app right sizing
you can ensure that your team will be
able to continuously practice
cost optimization for your gke clusters
you